[Musique]
notre ca ce soir diane bérard et nicolas
duvernois bonsoir à vous deux non ça on
va parler du réseau express
métropolitains le rem qui fait quand
même pas mal jaser ces jours ci
raismes phase 1 raismes de l'est reine
de la rive sud
on va parler du rem de lestienne d'abord
est ce qu on n'exclut trop rapidement
quand on parle de se re aiment de laisse
la possibilité que leur m soit
souterrain qu'il ne soit pas aérien en
pleine ville de montréal pour l'europe
de l'est est ce que la caisse a laissé
tomber trop rapidement la voie
souterraine pour vous allons-y avec un
peu de contexte on remonte à 2016 la
caisse présente un projet de très
rapides autonome qui va couvrir quatre
régions donc la branche cib rive sud où
un frein la sainte anne de bellevue
l'aéroport et de montagne alors tout se
passe pourquoi la caisse est sous
contrôle a parce qu'elle a réalisé le
skytrain la canada line à vancouver dont
on via coop de contrat pour cette raison
le pouce on arrive en 2020 2021 et le
tout à coup se rajoutent leur m2 lèvres
le possible m rincon
donc on a un contexte où ça va très vite
on vient de passer en vitesse supérieure
et pour cette raison là on en vient à
douter de la raison est pourquoi on
écarte si rapidement
tout va trop vite et là tout à coup on
écarte la portion souterraines
effectivement on commence à avoir des
doutes pu avoir un malaise autour de
toute sécurité nicolas mais moi je
comprends pas c'est quoi le l'obsession
de vouloir que ce soit sous terrain tout
cas hors terre en connaissant le
souterrain de montréal avec des tuyaux
qui date d'avant jésus-christ mais
j'aurais peur qu on ouvre une boîte de
pandore je lisais selon les experts un
rapport de certains experts qui disait
qu'il y avait des risques d'effondrement
de satellites au centre-ville de
montréal
le fait de le faire sous terrain risque
risquerait d'exploser les coûts d'avoir
des délais plus longs
sincèrement je ne comprends pas c'est
quoi ces squales accession le dampierre
aucun problème donc ces quads obsession
pourquoi faut faire ça souterrain tâche
tout je sais pas ok alors qu'il ya un
plan de match qui est fait et le plan de
match il est aérien
cela dit et des architectes qui ont des
styles démissionner parce qu'il trouve
ça très laid se noue alors diane qu'en
pensez-vous là dessus mais il ya un
enjeu un enjeu visuel il ya un an j'ai
une pollution visuelle de pollution
salaires donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut
évaluer un renne souterrain parce que je
te manque des enjeux architecturaux ils
ont aussi ce projet là pour des années
ont fait pour ce projet le post un cas
on le fait pour 25 ans d'ailleurs quand
on parle de ce qui se passe à québec on
aurait pas dire c'est pot longtemps pour
qu'on prenne les bonnes décisions ma
montréal faut que ça aille vite vite
vite donc à quelque part pourquoi on
veut faire un rennes s'intéresse pour
cette portion là pour ne pas défigurer
la métropole partout dans le monde on a
des autoroutes suspendu qu'on remet au
niveau du sol qui ont fait on fait des
parcs une et patrick piot voilà c'est
juste qu'en gustave eiffel a présenté la
tour eiffel tout le monde a trouvée
heureuse qu'on a chez habitat 67 tout le
monde trouvait ça affreux dati non mais
je pense pas que si on garde les pilotes
sur le banc dès la 40e
je sais pas on ne voit pas contents mais
oui on a vu sur la barre dès la 4
cantons quand on se promène on les voit
les pilotes des pylônes de dire m ont
commencé à ériger donc qu'elle autorise
également on voit on voit sa vie un
corridor aérien là sur une autoroute une
chose en pleine ville par exemple sur le
boulevard rené lévesque
c'est autre chose le questionnement le
questionnaire ce pot est simple un très
beau ça fait très beau au japon à tokyo
et vitré le train passe à beaucoup
d'endroits
élevé c'est très bien il semble que
beaucoup d'ailleurs beaucoup d'experts
d'architectes d'urbanistes qui ne semble
pas dire que c'est très beau donc
puisqu'on en parle comme ça et puisqu'un
débat et puisque de l'opposition et
puisque la caisse dit ah ça va coûter
trop cher puis le centre-ville pourrait
s'effondrer
est ce que ça veut donc dire qu'ils ont
un enjeu réel de consultation de
transparence sur ce plan là qu'on en dit
pas assez qu'on va pas assez loin pour
expliquer dionne mais je dirais la barre
que le tracé du rem de l'est a été
dévoilée en décembre alors que
l'autorité régionale de transport
metropolit et ont même pas commencé ses
consultations publiques sur le plat
stratégique de développement du
transport collectif
donc on est déjà un enjeu de taille mais
deuxièmement cpdq infra été très clair
sur le fait qu en consultation une
souhaite
non pas qu'on discute des possibilités
du trajet mais qu'on discute
d'aménagement autour du très ancien mais
j'appelle puceau de la consultation je
l'appelle sur la consultation très très
dirigé on est pas mal proche de
l'information donc un enjeu de taille
mais est-ce qu'on consulte où on annonce
et ça revient la question est ce que est
ce qu'on est à l'aise
nicolas devoir cdpq infra la caisse de
dépôt a géré pratiquement comme
sous-traitant la du gouvernement
essentiellement décidé d'avancer avec ce
type de projet l'a décidé de
l'organisation des transports collectifs
dans le grand montréal pour les
prochaines décennies
absolument moi je comprends je comprends
qu'elle ait personnes qui veulent
réfléchir 20 ans avant de déplacer les
placer un arbre mais quand on regarde la
réalité depuis 2007 que 15 ans puis sas
2007 c'était l'ouverture des trois
stations de métro de la capitale ont
fait en sorte que le métro se rendre à
laval est donc enfin retournons à 55 6
ans auparavant donc depuis vingt ans et
se passait rien tout d'un coup quelqu'un
est depuis 20 ans tout le monde
une pour que on améliore l'offre
quelqu'un arrive il
ils avancent vite il n'y a pas de
problème de financement les les trajets
sont définis et là tout d'un coup mais
il faut attendre comme ça
j'ai à me fait même s'il est imparfait
c'est ce que vous dites mais personne
n'a prouvé que ta part tu es tu dire que
c'est pas bon le ccc tellement subjectif
la caisse les experts avec des
ingénieurs des architectes des analystes
on dirait un réel danger de faire en
sorte de creuser dans le soutien de
montréal mais ok on a compris un danger
c'est le souterrain moi je veux que ça
avance parce que ce n'est tous les
points ce train là pire ne brisons
dionne
mais pourquoi les autres villes ont des
cocktails de transport berlais vienne
paris et pourquoi depuis cdpq un froid
qui s'occupe de ce dossier là tout ce
dont on a besoin c'est le rêve je me
pense mais je sais pourquoi y apparaître
13 partout nikola dit je te réponds que
ce n'est pas la même réalité financière
de comparer paris 15 15 à 20 millions de
personnes action prendre l'agglomération
qui prennent très très très souvent les
plusieurs fois par jour lié le transport
en commun avec plus de 260 stations de
métro plutôt qu'ici le métro c'est un
métro du centre-ville
ici on a deux millions de personnes sur
l'île de montréal
c'est pas la même réalité financière non
plus pour financer tout ça c'est le
monde on réfléchit à un projet
d'envergure on se contente plus grandes
villes du monde
on a lui les moyens ni la masse octroie
sûr que les yoles alors j'ajouterai un
autre point c'est l'intégration
jusqu'à quel point est-ce que cdpq un
froid travaille de concert avec l'
agence régionale métropolitaine de
transport il ya une question
d'intégration aussi y reste je suis
d'accord avec avec toi nicolas on n'est
pas de la taille de paris mais la
question d'intégrer tous les transports
est super important et il ne me semble
pas qu'une grande collégialité entre ses
défauts qui avance et l' agence
régionale le montant de transport
collectif qui va affecter des
collectivités donc c'est la
responsabilité du gouvernement les
agences gouvernementales de faire le
trafic de choisir le cocktail de
transport ok oui mais tiennent avant le
rêve ne vais pas points d'entente entre
littrell yvelines
les autobus de banlieue que le métro de
montréal c'est un maelström depuis le
début parce qu'on se divise tout en sous
comité les neiges
or qui va avancer et peu de challenge et
souple elle pas fait je vous invite à
lire mon collègue michel c'est auger sur
cet enjeu durable il ya quelques jours
textes intéressants critique de ce
dossier bien sûr diane merci et nicolas
également merci beaucoup
manoir il pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit